yeah hey everybody i'm super
cool to be talking from you now and
let me just screen
so as russian are we going to talk a bit
about how to use jackson flags in
transformers i think yesterday um
you you've seen how to or you've heard
how to use jackson flex in general
so today it's a bit more about um how we
integrated jackson flex into
transformers so syrah's going to kick it
off by
the design philosophy for jackson flags
in transformers
and also explain a bit more um how the
models are kind of built up and how the
inference works and how the training
works in transformers
then in the second part um i show you
how the the hacking phase hub can be
used
for collaboration for for your projects
during the community week
and um how to make use of our kit
version control
awesome all right do you wanna go ahead
yeah sure thanks patrick so let me just
start by sharing my screen
awesome can you see my screen
yep
cool so i'll talk about talk a bit about
transformers and then we will go over
the design of flex modes and
transformers how we can use them
and how we can write trading script for
those models so
so that we can train those models all
right so what is transformers
so transformers is an open source
natural language processing library
and right now it's one of the most
popular library of github
we have more than 45 000 stars and 800
plus active contributors
and right now it's being used in
production in more than 5000 plus
companies and at transformers our goal
is to democratize natural language
processing and by that
i mean providing access to
state-of-the-art models to a single
unified api
so that any user can easily access
different
sota nlp models and easily switch
between those without having to
learn different apis or different
frameworks and recently we have also
started supporting other modalities
like speech and vision so we have
uh integrated open eyes clip and vit
and the two very popular speech models
like welcome week 2 and
then the hubert model that facebook
released last week
all right now let's dive into
jack's flags and how those models are
implemented in
transformers okay so we'll talk a bit
about pytorch versus jax and this is
intended to like show you the difference
between how our touch models behave and
how flax waters behave
and then why did we make the design
choices that we made
all right so in general flax uh pythos
models are considered stateful
and by stateful what i mean is when you
define a python model
like this so consider a simple
self-attention module which
contains keys values and curious
matrices and a logit projection
you define the layers and when you
define the layers python also
initializes their weights
and stores inside the modules so you can
see
in the diagram on the right that you
have the layers
and it also stores your weights and when
you are doing a forward pass and the
backward pro
record propagation these parameters are
updated in place
by the optimizer so everything happens
inside the module but as opposed to that
flex models are stateless and by
stateless what i mean
is when you define a model like this
model flags
in in flags library this this definition
usually just tells
the module that what kind of computation
to do and what kind of parameters to
expect so it does not initialize any
parameters beforehand so if you look at
this diagram
this just contains the layer definitions
and it also stores like other metadata
like shape and etc but it does not
initialize
any parameters and this is because flax
is based on jacks
and in jacks most transformations like
jacks.jet or jax.pmap
expect the function that they transform
to be stateless and to have
no side effects and this is because jax
functions are
usually compiled and when you compile a
function
the side effect is only executed once
and the compile function will
will execute the same side effect over
and over again
so that it's the code becomes unreliable
all right now so how to do when you do a
forward pass with the stateful model it
usually look like
looks like this so your model already
contains the parameters
and you just need to pass the inputs
which are here called
input ids so the model takes the input
it has the weights and it does the
forward
pass and returns you the output whereas
in flags
as the ball the model does not contain
any weights it does not maintain any
state you need to pass it
the inputs as well as the states so
which you can see here
the apply method this is the input id
and the state
so the state is composed of the
parameters and other variables like
batch num statistics and etc
so again to explain the clear difference
between pythagorean squad is
in flags you need to pass your
input input examples and your parameters
explicitly and the flex model does not
maintain
any state okay now let's see
how you can use flex modulation
transformers so if you look at this
slide
you can see that it has the familiar
transformers api so the from pre-10
meter separate
method and the call method so to
initialize the to load the weights to
save the weights and to do a forward
pass
so this looks very much stateful so how
do we handle the statelessness of jax
flags if our model looks
stateful so that is
taken care of by this class called flex
printed model
class which is an abstract class which
kind of like a wrapper
which wraps the flex module which is
written here as a module class and it
provides two important important methods
called init weights
and under call which takes care of
initializing your weights when you
initialize
the model and the render call method
takes care
of doing the forward pass by taking the
inputs
and the parameters so the initiate
methods
calls the init method on the wrapped
flux module
and returns the parameters and then this
initiative methods
is called in the underscore under init
methods
and the parameters are stored in this
self.params attribute
and then you have your familiar from
patent and separated method so that you
can easily load
and save which now if you want to define
your own flex model that has this
similar api how can you do that
so we need to like kind of do three
steps first you will write your flex
module the way you usually write the
flex code
so let's consider a simple mlp example
here we have two dense layers and
we do the forward pass called dense
layer then relu and then the second
dense layer
so you define the flex module then
what you need to do is you need to
create another class by subclassing this
flags
pre-trained model class and then you
need to overwrite the init weights
and the under call methods so in the
inside the inequals method
you kind of give the oranges which are
which are required for like initializing
the parameters and for
dropouts and etc and then you also give
the input shape
because to unify the flex what is weight
you need to pass a dummy example to do
the forward pass and
do it through the weights so we
initialize our input a double input here
we initialize
the necessary arranges and then we call
self.module.init which
takes the interrupt flex module passes
it the rng then inputs
and returns the parameters which are
then stored in this
pre-10 modules instance with and then
those
those can be accessed using model dot
params attribute
and in the under call method you define
all the meth all the attributes or all
the parameters
the inputs that your model is going to
take and also the parameters that it is
going to take
and so when you don't pass any
parameters which are by default none
the model will use the stored parameters
which could be
randomly initialized or which could be
loaded from the from written method and
then it just simply calls
the module.apply method which flax uses
to do
the forward pass so because of this
you can uh without having to use that
and or the init
init method or the apply method you can
simply call them the call and the model
and simply you need the module as you
insert you need
any python object now
to actually define your module what you
need to do is you need to create another
class called
flexibility model you sub class it and
then you set the
module class attribute here so which
tells the pre-10 module class what
modules to expect
and what module to initialize etc so
once you do that your models will have
the same api as
with any transfer as any other
transformer models in the library so it
will have access to front written method
separated method and then you could
easily do
forward pass by uh simply calling the
render call method which is
called by default when you call the
module instance again
the important point to note here is that
this model is
not an instance of an end of module it's
just an abstract class
which wraps the ending dot the flexes
and end of module and just provides you
convenient methods to work with
awesome so now let's see how we can
train these flex models in transformers
so to usually train any flex model what
you need
is a loss function that takes the
parameters and the inputs
and the forward pass and returns the
loss and then you need
also an optimizer which takes the
gradients and parameters
and then returns the update parameters
updated parameters
and then it's simple a trend function
which does
the forward and backward pass that is it
runs the loss function
the forward pass gets the loss passes it
to the optimizer
and returns the updated parameters
so usually a simple training example
will look like this
so you define a method called a loss
function
function called loss function or compute
loss and it takes
all the necessary states which is the
parameters
input ids and labels then we do the
forward pass
by passing the model the input ids and
parameters
again the important thing here is that
when you are training the
model training a flux model you need to
pass these parameters
explicitly as as i said as i said in the
previous slide flux does not
store any parameters then you calculate
the loss then return the loss
then to take the gradient of the loss
you we need to
transform it using the jack stop value
and grad
function uh we use the op text library
to uh use for optimization so you just
pass
you just define what optimizer you want
so here we are using the sgd
optimizer and then you initialize the
optimize the state by passing it
the initialized patterns then inside the
trend function i get unique to pass in
the whole state that is the parameters
optimizer states any other arranges they
don't
if those are needed and then the inputs
and outputs which are input ids and
labels so the 10 steps then
calls the grad function which is
by passing it the parameters input adds
labels it then returns loss and graphs
then you just call tx dot update which
returns you the updated optimizer state
and updated parameter
updated october states then you can
apply updates by passing in the
parameters and updates
which then returns the update params as
you can see here
you always explicitly need to pass the
parameters and
the new state and all the jacks function
or the flux functions
returns you new updated parameters and
updated states
without updating in place then the train
step gives us this
updated parameter states and loss then
in the next step
we usually did the training step so that
we get the maximum performance that is
possible
uh if you are doing distributed training
or uh for on multiple devices you will
usually use desktop pmat
but uh we'll explain those more in the
docs because we won't get that get much
time to explain it here
all right so once you have your train
step then you can just simply write a
loop
and keep passing on your inputs so here
we call the transduct method inside the
loop
we always pass it the parameters
optimize the states and the inputs and
delay
and the outputs and then it returns the
new updated parameters
and optimizer states which we then pass
against that's how our parameters get
updated
okay so uh this is how you can like
simply define a simple
uh training training loop for flex
models all right that's it from uh my
side
or geopatrick
all right great i'm going to start
showing my screen now
great okay so i'm going to give you
a little demo on how you can use the the
hub during your
during the community week so um first of
all i want to explain a bit how the hub
works
um so here you can see we have models
data sets and resources
and what you would probably do is to
check out existing models we already
have a lot of models
in the hub and many of you will probably
use pre-trained models
or at least check out the configuration
of existing models when you want to
train a model from scratch
so here on the left you can filter by
tasks
and then below here you can filter our
library so for this community week we
should
filter jacks because we want um to see
how many models we can use for jags
um we have four thousand here and then a
lot of projects are also um
specific for a language so here you can
kind of decide on your language code so
let's
say we're going to use some german
models and
we filter by de the language code and
then you can see all the models here so
then we could also
search for specific model let's say bird
in case you want to
fine-tune a pre-trained bird for a
project you can click on it
and then you can see all the information
about the model here so um
that's just in general how you can kind
of use the hub to
to find a good model or a good
configuration you want to use
all right now let's demo a bit how you
can actually use the hub doing
training so um we created this
organization which is called flux
community and we already have a lot of
members which is awesome
um and it would be great if you can
upload your mobile repositories
to this organization and this for once
this helps us to have a good overview
and second of all we can help you
because you can directly
access the organization and everybody
can access all repositories so you can
help each other
which is nice all right um let's do a
little
demo now um so we create a model and
we're going to create it under the flux
community
so on the organization so everybody has
access to it and we're just going to
call it roberto
base and then else so what i do here is
i'm just going to
pre-train a roberto on a very very low
resource language
on the oscar dataset which is called
alts
so we'll just do that and then create
the model
oh it actually already exists so let's
go demo
cool so now you can see we've created
this model and by doing so we've
created a git repository essentially so
this
identifier now is a git repository for
um your
for the project and what we'll do now is
we'll clone it
so we'll just copy that and so you can
find here to clone it you need to
install git lfs for that so you can
upload
the heavy model weights um and then you
can see the link here so essentially
those two commands
um give you a git clone so now i'm just
going to show how you can do this in
your console so we run this command
and we can see now that um we've cloned
the repository locally so this is the
project essentially now this is our
project where we want to pre-train
roberto base
on almonic and as you can see here
um it's essentially a git repository so
we have first commit initial commit we
created it
um and you can use it just like a git
repository which is very nice
and now i've wrapped some some code
so in the beginning what we're going to
do is we're going to move the code that
we need inside the repo so that we can
um
track it and you can see now that the
state changed
and we've added a file that you can
track and we're going to run this
and this is just gonna
create a convict for us so as you can
see here it has created a roberta for
muscle m config
a very basic one and now
we've added a file to it config.json
file all right
then we'll also create a tokenizer
so um i'm just going to run that as well
luckily the data set is super small so
this actually runs quite fast
um so what we do here now is that we
train
a new token as a byte level vpe
tokenizer on the small data set
and it should also just take a couple of
seconds actually so it's already
finished great
now you can see we have the token.json
file as well
um and now we want to do is you want to
actually upload all the smallest um so
here so we can say add config tokenizer
and now we add an upload
all the files to our repo cool also
now we can start training the models
we've defined the config and we've
defined the tokenizer so we can
initialize as a random model from our
config and use the tokenizer to process
the data so we'll do the same thing here
we'll move our scripts the bash script
into the repository and also
the training script
and run that as well this is going to
take a bit longer but essentially what
we do now is we
train the whole model from scratch um so
the run if i
show you a bit how this looks like
this is just a bash script that runs the
general run mlm flag script that we uh
that we've uploaded to the examples
folder so you have access to that
um for most projects that just pre-train
uh roberta or gpt from scratch you can
actually use these uh
these scripts out of the box you just
have to define
the the fitting language here and then
also the model type
cool all right so it's gonna train now
it's gonna be pretty fast actually
um but in the meantime i wanna show you
what happened now
to our repository online so now
you can see that we've uploaded the
files here so we have a git history
as you have in our git repository as you
can see here
and we've added the files which is very
nice you see exactly what happened
config and all the files
and you can also go back to commits
and for example if you deleted a file by
accident or whatever and so that's very
nice actually kind of keep track of your
work
and everybody in your team has access to
this repository
so it's very easy to collaborate on that
great okay let's see how our training is
doing okay
still running so it's
so the beginning is always a bit slower
because it has to compile in gpu
so you will um you'll often see this in
the beginning that it seems to be
freezing
in the very beginning but that just
means that the code has been compiled
and now you can see it's very fast so
once it starts
um the gpu is actually very fast so now
we finish one epoch
you can see the loss and now with the
elevation
and so what's happening now is actually
that we we upload
both the weights and the tensorflow logs
directly to the hub
so we've defined this in
our bash script here we've added a flag
which is called push to hub
and this allows you to directly upload
the tensorflow board traces
and the flags way to the hub which is
very nice
and the cool thing now is that you can
see this directly
in our demo so when you check out this
reaper now here you can see there's a
new tab which is called training metrics
when you click on it
you can actually see the tensorboard
live
so this is very convenient um if you
want to share your your progress um
with with other teams or with the
organizers we can take a look at your
tensor
and bot traces and as your at the edge
locks to identify
bugs or other things so this can be very
convenient
um in most scripts or actually all flag
scripts they have this um
this push to hub flag right here and we
strongly recommend that you can use that
so that um you have access to the
tensorflow or
the tensorboard logs right away here all
right
great i think that's it um
[Music]
and i'll stop sharing my screen great so
um
i think now we have some five minutes
left for
for questions so we can answer them
um all right maybe i'll just go through
the chat
so
[Music]
how do we set up write access for team
members here so the right access is um
that's a good question so because we
give everybody access to the
organization which is called flex
community
everybody has right access to all github
repositories um what we would like to
see is that
team members kind of only only write to
their repo
in the beginning but then eventually
when other tips
want to help a certain member then
you can also directly write into other
repositories which don't belong to your
product or your team
so we think this is the best way of kind
of sharing collaborating
as a community
yeah we uh we kind of hope that people
don't mess with other repo so um
you you shouldn't go into other repos
and delete files you'll be able to do
this but then
we keep track of the locks and we can
obviously revert this
since we have a get version yeah control
it's also it's a very good question so
we recommend to actually keep all
the code that you have in the in this
repo so
even if you use an official trading
script like i just did um
we recommend that you copy it into the
repo and upload it
um essentially you can you should have
all
everything that you need for the project
inside this repo so the model weights
um thanks to get lfs you can upload this
um
all all locks during training and all
code that you wrote so that's the best
way for us to find bugs and to reproduce
also training runs the only thing i
guess that you shouldn't have
is the other data files so if you have a
data set of 100 gigabyte
then maybe um just just leave the code
in the downloads the data but don't
add all the data files into into the
repo
great
is it possible to share with multiple
v38s for the same training i am not sure
actually
i haven't tried that yet i think it's
going to be hard because it's different
gpus
sorry um
cool yeah then information about
pre-training gpt2 we have very nice
collapse so if you go to
the official flex example folders and
then to the readme you can see there's a
this gpt collab which explains
everything step by step
so that's very nice
[Music]
then we have to make two questions so we
have to vac um the inference is fully
tested so inference works you can try it
out so you can transcribe speech with um
with existing models the the
pre-training script is also tested
it works i haven't done a complete
pre-training yet but um
it should work so i did some integration
tests with the official faresec code
and all right
can we pre-train the bar from scratch um
yeah well you can we don't have to
we don't have the official kind of bar
pre-training as a script right now we
have an official t5 pre-training script
but not the bob pre-training so bart
used um a slightly different
pre-training algorithm than t5
so we don't have that yet um we
recommend actually using t5
if you want to pre-train a sector stack
from scratch but we have a bard
summarization script so everything which
is fine tuning
is should be very easy for for
all kinds of sector stack models
all right i think i'll give it back to
susanna
that sounds great thank you for taking
over the questions that was great
um yeah cool thank you both for for your
talks um that was really great good to
see a demo
i think that helped a lot um a lot of
participants as well today
we did have like a few more questions
related questions how to get started
with tpu
tpu vms um cloud tpus we had
a really great talk yesterday by sky we
introduced that
a bit so you can watch that as soon as
it's online and suraj also shared the
docs
um for user's guide to tpu dams
um awesome that was our first talk thank
you so much guys that was great
and i think we can move on to the second
talk of the day
um sabrina sabrina whenever you're ready
um you can start sharing
um your slides maybe i'll introduce you
meanwhile sabrina is a phd student
at the johns hopks hopkins university
and she's also a tugging phase part-time
and she'll talk today about how to go
from stateful code to purified jax and
how to build your neural net framework
super excited to hear about that
okay awesome uh yeah thanks for the
introduction um
that's basically what i'm gonna be
talking about um how do you actually
make that step from like reading like
the jacks intro docs and being like okay
so this is like numpy but cooler or
something
um to building frameworks like we've
seen with flux yesterday and today
so um i'm just basically gonna jump
right into it
um this is from a paper that or i wrote
a few
a few a few months ago um we were like
doing some k-means clustering and i was
like hey
we could just put this on the gpu with
jax and voila you get great
savings it's fast hooray um i think
someone someone
had this tweet yesterday in their talk
and this is the one time jeff dean who
tweeted me and i was like ah
oh my god 15. um and you might also have
used jacks for getting uh
an easy way to do like autograph for for
functions
so this is a kind of convoluted example
there's definitely no need to look at it
in detail but if you know what
reversible jump mcmc is
you know that you need the jacobian
determinant of the diphthomorphism
that's involved
and you know basically fancy gradient
taking diphthomorphism well i define a
python function and then jax really does
all the rest for me i'm like
looking at the um jacobian right here
and then take its determinant the
absolute value and it just
very nice and easy it makes sense like
this is kind of what it feels like jax's
um gradient taking is made for it's it's
kind of like yeah you have a function
it depends on some arguments i can get
the gradient of
the scalar output with respect to one of
the arguments by default the first one
great um but this is quite different
from what we might know from
oh yeah and also speed this is quite
different from what we know from uh
frameworks like high torch so in pytorch
um or or also like um
eager tensorflow um we built up our our
execution graph
um like so what step by step we say this
is a tensor
and then a new tensor is created and so
on
and what happens when we call dot
backward is that this whole
graph is traversed backwards um we can
also call this tape based it's like kind
of
keeping track on a tape what happened
and then going back down the tape
and okay we get radiance this way and
that's
what when i started learning about jax a
little over a year ago um
that's what i was familiar with right so
how do we go from this
to what's happening in jax where
functions are pure
i i remember someone asked about this in
the previous talk and that's going to be
great because we're going to be
coming back to it um when a function is
pure like it has these arguments w
and x and then return something and then
if we do the gradient thing it basically
gives us a new function
that's also pure again we'll talk about
that later
and now it gives us the gradient um off
the output
with respect to in this case the first
parameter because we didn't specify
anything else
um and so that is how we could get
gradients i suppose
right um you see that in this case the
gradient um is
is this number 42. okay fine um
but this is kind of small and silly and
like
how do i train big models with lots of
tensors complicated functions and
things that aren't pure so that's what
we're going to be doing
in this talk um or put differently how
can weights and gradients be stateful or
other
answers can't be mutated um for those
for those who spend too much time online
like me
um i'm going to say in the very
beginning uh this talk is based on a
blog post that i wrote in
march 2020 so you might say okay wow
that was a that was a long time ago is
this blog post still relevant like isn't
this kind of outdated
um and the good answer is um absolutely
not it's it has never been relevant
uh it has always been a silly little
teaching experiment
more so than a canonical thing of like
oh this is how you should do
things um the good side of that is it
will never not be relevant
and i think that the ideas in there will
hopefully help you get a sense of why
the frameworks that you've seen
yesterday and today
look the way they do and what's really
happening in there
so what we're going to accomplish is
explicitly not building any great models
or
beautiful frameworks we're not going to
be idiomatic and elegant
my code is going to be nasty and messy
in some parts and
definitely not safe for work um
there's also not going to be any
batching and distributing and and
compiling with jit and you might say wow
okay so there's going to be nothing in
here
what we are going to be doing is um
really uh taking a small example in this
case linear regression
doing it statefully in pi torch and then
being like wow how do we transfer this
um when we move to jax and try to be
pure um we'll have a little aside it's
like oh this is another way you could do
it
that hasn't really panned out um
and then basically built up what these
frameworks that we see
um are doing let's get right into it um
this is what a
module and pi torch looks like um if you
have never coded
torch or either tensorflow and this is
your first neural network wow
um okay cool but otherwise probably
you've seen some of this right there's
like
we've seen this in the talk just before
modules that own their weights
it's like um this is just a tensor and
we
give it some some initialization and so
the class now owns its weights
it can use it when building this
execution graph when compiling this tape
and then when we use this so this is the
two steps we've just seen before in a
training in a training loop
we can do last.backwards which writes
the gradients next to the tensors
and then update each parameter's data
by in this case subtracting the gradient
so this would just be vanilla sgd
and this means that yes there is this
one module it owns its weights and we
mutate those things
um that is a little bit of a big example
so at this point i'm going to switch
to a notebook and i hope everyone can
see this
let me know if not this is also the
first time that i've
given a talk with the notebook so this
will be super fun i'm very excited
let's actually look at much at a much
simpler example so this
is something um we are just defining 1d
linear regression you know this from
school
um there's going to be like a weight and
a bias if you want to call it that
and the formula is pretty simple the
weight multiplied by the
input plus device for training
i'm going to define this function for a
root mean squared error again
pretty standard we're looking at the
results
how far is it off from the goals the y's
square the whole thing
take the mean and take the root okay so
far so good um and
create this as a class so this is just
standard pie chart stuff i can i can
show you this
this works here
let's predict it from 3.0 and since
we've initialized it to zero we should
expect
zero yep zero comes out we see that
there's a gradient function associated
with it with the whole tape based
shenanigans
we can also test our other function um
if we define um our training pairs to be
that
three should result in seven okay
there's a loss of seven that makes sense
because
zero and seven are seven apart so far so
incredibly boring
um it's gonna get worse we're going to
also write an sgd loop in high torch
um i've given i've given you one more
training example so we're not completely
under defined
um and then yeah you get the loss you
backwards
you update your parameters you zero your
gradients never forget that
um and then see what happens and we see
that as training goes on yeah we get
kind of close to the seven
now this is pretty pretty poor std so
we're not really hitting it nicely but
you get the idea this is actually doing
what it's supposed to do
so what could that look like in jax
um again we could start with something
that's very similar we have a linear
regressor class uh
has a weight and a bias that owns them
um i could i could make these um
uh jnp erase if i wanted to it doesn't
really matter
um we have a prediction we have this
thing it's literally the same thing
except i replace torch with jnp
it's so nice that we all somewhat
standardize on the same thing this is
this is great
and now i have the thing and it's great
yep
this is on cpu no worries let's do the
same tests again
yes we get zero and the loss is 7.0
um so that's nice and all but but okay
now now
now now what uh how do we how do we how
do we train things
right like we have a loss but we can't
call that backwards
we need to have some pure function if we
go back to this
um some pure function that
we can sort of invert or take the
gradient off
so where does this pure function come in
to talk about that um let's actually do
a little
interlude on purity
i'm gonna even give this its own
headline um what is purity
here are three examples of functions two
that are pure and one that is impure
um a pure function generally the idea is
that well it kind of takes some values
and it outputs some values and it
doesn't interact with anything outside
the function
it doesn't mutate anything right except
for what's contained in itself
and it doesn't access anything it wasn't
explicitly given as a parameter
so this function is clearly fine um it
only gets an x it only accesses the x it
doesn't mutate anything or something
great
this function on the other hand in
python would not be fine because
um the list excess that is being passed
is actually mutated and so
if i were to call this um we can just do
this
into your function one um access
let's see um let's find out like that oh
well
let's call it l just so we're not
confused with the other code
um you can see that the list after
calling this function
is now changed so this function is
impure okay
um this on the other hand would be fine
because stateful mutation inside the
function
well that's no problem right so
um this would return a new list
that in this case has these uh has these
this changed values
but the original list importantly is
still the same so that's pure
give you some more examples for impurity
um
this is another kind of classical one um
if we have some global state like in
this case number of executions
and the function mutates that that is
very clearly impure
um but even just accessing the state
is impure the reason the reason being
that if i call
in pure function three on uh value three
okay well i got uh i got a zero
um but now i
[Music]
uh
and call it again we see that this says
this has changed
um so that sucks and so this is already
giving us a sense
of what is going to be an easy check for
purity and is i think my favorite
mnemonic for this
um if the function could just be a
lookup table
or you could cache the function and
nobody would notice
except for that it might be faster then
it's pure
and so that i think is a great check to
actually check if something is pure
if you can replace it with a lookup
table and this seems kind of outrageous
um then it is a pure function and you'll
see that this is true for those things
we could replace those with a lookup
table i mean
we might give this this beautiful uh
python decorator for caching
and nobody would notice but we couldn't
do it for these functions
um finally last classic examples um
if you if you use um io like you print
things
you get user input or you try to get the
current system time
those are all impure um and it makes
sense because you couldn't cache these
this could change
all the time um i'll give you one
one thing um if you paid attention
during the previous talk
you kind of know why this one isn't
impure and um
i would like to just someone shout it
out in chat
uh i should actually open the chat
window shouldn't i
um awesome um yeah just shout out and
chat
why is this function in pure what's
wrong with it
something about random numbers right but
uh
yeah so so exactly so this kind of
violates kind of both both sides of this
for one it mutates the global random
state because it advances the number
generator
and it's not reproducible in the sense
that if i call this twice it's just not
going to give me the same example
so that's another classic impure
function
um i also should have probably looked at
the chat a little bit earlier
but one thing that is really important
to me this is not comic sans it's comic
code it's my favorite coding font
it's beautiful um okay that is it um
let's go on with this then uh let me
move the chat over here
cool so um how do we build a pure
function
for training okay this is kind of a side
is now over
to work um we could build something like
this
so this is a loss function that uses our
rhythmia regressor class
it sets the weight and the bias and then
gives us the
error for the data and you see that i
explicitly
pass in the um the parameters here
and set them like that it's a little
ugly and i need to enumerate all the
parameters
definitely not something we want to do
but i mean i guess it works
it gives us the right loss and
importantly
we could actually train with this so
again use the same training data
and now we can calculate the loss with
this last function
and what we're going to be doing here is
this um
maybe i should just show this in
isolation um
if we do jack squad on the loss function
it gives us a function right and we can
call this
on our our our oops on our data
what did i mess up oh yeah i need to
pass in w and b
let's just say zero um and it would give
me
a number what is this number it's the
gradient
of the loss with respect to the first
parameter ah but we want the gradient
with respect to both parameters
and so we can pass in our numbers um and
so it gives us
both these gradients cool um so that's
what we're writing here these are the
gradients and then
again just um apply them to
these um weights that this module owns
so this is kind of a kind of
haphazard uh high torch direct
implementation
but you see it does train and it gets
gets the job done
so cool good for us i hate it though
i really hate that i have to put the uh
w
and bay in here like that um and we
probably want to do better so
let's get rid of this i don't like this
class anymore we're going to do it
differently
um instead we're going to have all our
parameters in a dictionary now and
you've seen this in flex and other
frameworks
that's really how it works it's
dictionaries it's frozen dicks
this is how it's going to be and the
beautiful thing about this is
that jax is able to deal with not just
scalars or vectors or lists or tuples
but also dictionaries
as arguments and so now this is
basically the same as we've written
before
except we didn't have to write out w and
b up here we just did the params and
then access them here
set them otherwise exactly same thing
um why is this different
i'm guessing because we already trained
oops
this should wait a second why is this
different oh sorry yeah
because we uh have these complicated
examples instead of the simple one
all right so far so good um we can again
get gradients
um if i type this in um just out of
curiosity
what do you think is going to come out
feel free to post it in chat what is the
type of gradients what is this going to
be
it's the gradients of that last scalar
with respect to the first parameter
that's a dictionary
right it's a dictionary
and it contains the gradients for the
parameters so now we can we can
apply them like this okay sure um and
the loss has gone down
okay that's good let's go down always
good love to see it
um but we can do something a little bit
nicer than enumerating these
um and that is we can just combine these
two dictionaries
with a tree map is what it's called in a
tree multi-map that's what it's called
in jacks
um i'm not going to go into too much
detail but basically it does what you
think it does
it takes the two dictionaries and for
all the keys that match
um combines them using a function and
this function in this case i've written
something incredibly simple it just
takes the first value and subtracts the
second one so that's exactly what we
want for an update
and so if we do this um yeah the
parameters are going to change
so this is our new my parameters and the
loss has gone down
yet again hooray um and with this we can
write we can write a training loop that
is
not too terrible like this is actually
not awful
in my opinion um we get the loss we do
the gradients
um we just have this my params
dictionary we update the parameters and
off we go
and this is a little bit awkward um just
just to see that we can get close to the
right values and we are
so bear with me we're going to make this
a little bit nicer too in just
a second okay so far so good
um everyone everyone's still on board
we have taken this taken this example
and kind of translated it to something
in jax that is not
terrible by making use of the fact that
we can have parameters and dicks
okay so um if you want a little break
this is the time because it's time for
an aside
um we're gonna be doing something that
is really fun
um and that i think is somewhat
obvious uh to do which is why i think
it's fun to cover it
and that is we're going to make this a
little bit cooler and instead of
dictionaries
use our classes as pie tree nodes what
do i mean by pie tree nodes
that's really what i was saying that jax
can accept scalars vectors lists
tuples dictionaries because all of these
are
registered as pi 3 nodes and so we can
use this tree multi-map on them
and the cool thing is we can make our
own classes
pi tree nodes as well so we can take our
regressor class
and define um 42 functions flatten
and unflatten and what they basically do
is
flatten takes a regressor instance and
converts it into this tuple of
leads which contain the actual numeric
data the scalars
the the weights really and some
auxiliary information in this case we
don't need it because this class is dead
simple
and unflattened which does the same
thing um given the auxiliary information
in the leaves
gives us um a new instance of this
regressor
so one thing to to be careful um the
order changes this is
incredibly sad but alas such as baggage
from the past
either way this is not too terrible to
write and once we've written this and
registered this as a pie tree node
we can now do cool things like this our
last function can now actually take
the regressor the class as an argument
okay so again we get the loss we want
cool um i'm going to ask again now we're
going to do gradients with respect to
the first thing what is it we're going
to get
person in chat
[Music]
what is the type of gradients going to
be
this is kind of it is a pie tree note
but it's a very specific pie tree note
gradients is going to be a regressor
it's going to be the class that we want
and its weight and bias is actually
going to have the gradients in the leaf
exactly kevin
that's exactly what's happening um so we
can uh
look at this yes it contains it contains
the gradients
so this is cool and you can imagine yeah
what's happening is that this is just
being bijects this is being flattened
so it's just a bunch of scalers magic
happens and then it's being unflattened
again and returned to us
as a regressor and now again we can just
do the tree multi-map thing and combine
our regressor that holds the weights
with the regressor that holds the
gradients
and voila loss goes down
this is cool um and i think this is a
this is an incredibly kind of uh
appealing and intuitive way of doing
things and if you think the same way
well i got something for you um you just
add a little bit more magic
namely something that writes the
flattened and unflattened logic
for you so you don't have to write it by
doing type annotation
magic and some hijacking just like
initialization stuff that we're going to
talk to later and you get
the sasha russian i um tried to build
uh last last summer and we got a little
bit into it it has
it's basically runnable um we kind of
gave up once we didn't really know how
to implement that norm because
statefulness but check this out if you
think this is an interesting approach
so that's kind of taken this idea
further
that's all i'm going to say about this
idea
this is the assignment over um we're
going to go back to our regular
schedule programming
namely the dictionaries because that's
really what most of the things
most of the frameworks are using and we
can make this a little bit nicer and
introduce another
cool concept that is really going to dry
from what's happening
frameworks like haiku and flux
so i'm going to do something um i'm
going to
first of all go back to my slides and
say what we want
is we want to purify code
what did i mean by this um we really
kind of
want users to be able to write stateful
methods like we did in pytorch because
it is nice to just say self.w
plus something and it kind of works out
um and we would like to have a framework
that purifies these functions that
creates things like this
loss function that we manually created
and how that's going to work is like
this
this is kind of what we want users to be
able to write
um to have organ like forward or call
all these displays and access them
and that makes this function impure so
we cannot call grad on it
which sucks and the trick we're going to
do is we're going to wrap this function
in what i will call a purified function
so the user writes the same function as
before it accesses w this is not cool
but we can create a new purified
function that also takes w
as a parameter and first thing
says that to be
to be this value that's being accessed
then we can call you the user function
so the user function says oh i hate full
class thing but
joke's on you we just said that we just
set it from the parameter so no
information from outside this purified
function
was actually accessed this is great we
also remove it afterwards just in case
in each face
you know take nothing but memories leave
nothing but footprints um
and we return the results that this
messy impure user function
created and so this function purified f
that is going to be something we can
totally call grad on
so a little bit more specifically this
is what we're going to be working
towards this is the
tiny framework that i'm going to be
building up in the remainder of our time
um where we're not quite using self.w we
have this method called self dot
get parameter okay fine um but i figure
it's close enough
we also give that its initializer um so
this is similar enough at least to what
we saw on high torch
we use it as normal so
this is great and down here um
skipping the magic bit in the middle for
a second what we want
is we want to be able to get initial
parameters
without having to write them out like we
did before
um and we want to be able to use those
parameters
to call this purified function get its
gradients get the gradients and update
as before
so just to be clear on this the benefit
of this
over what we've seen um right here
before we went to our little aside
sorry let me just uh get that up again
um is that we didn't have to actually um
do do this okay we already did that with
gmap but we didn't have to explicitly
enumerate parameters
so that would be nice and the key
ingredient is going to be this bit of
magic that i'm going to call
purify and that's going to take this
impure function
and return a function um that is the
purified version
and a function that initializes the
parameters and gives us this initial
dictionary
and if you paid attention you already
know where this is going this is apply
and this is in it
in flex and high skaiku but okay how do
we build that up
um let's implement this uh step by step
um i
realized we're a little bit strapped for
time but i think it's gonna be fine if
we take this um
because i think this is really the core
of what we're gonna get at
let's implement this little flowchartic
thing that i made
in code so um
i have of course already done this this
is what it could look like again this is
our impure function
um i have done uh i've used the
dictionary already here but
the idea is the same the parameters are
none
and the purified function takes
parameters sets the parameters
calls the messy user function which of
course uses self params but jokes on
them because we set that just now
and then we zero out the parameters
after we turn whatever the user function
gave us
um this doesn't deal with the
initialization yet so okay we specify
that manually
but we can call this i'm going to use
jack's value and grad
in this example because it is what you
probably want to do
um and so we can get lost in gradients
from this again
using it exactly as before except i was
lazy and use this function because
less writing and you see okay yep the
losses as it was we get the gradients
and now we could pre-multi-map those
gradients with our parameters
cool so this is the idea
on this specific example but if we want
to build a framework of course
we're going to have to do a little bit
of abstraction so i'm going to
put right here i guess i'll have to zoom
out to make it fit
um but this class i hope you can i hope
you can read this um
a little bit more okay fine um what this
class is going to look like
um so this is going to be our base
neural network module it's going to
have the parameters as before and we're
also going to have flags that say are we
running in pure mode are we running an
initializing mode
this is going to be the get parameter
and so if we are running in pure mode
just return the parameters if we are
running an initializing mode
then set the parameters to something
that the initializer
that we specify gave us and so
this way we can
and now create these two methods that
both similar like kind of do the same
thing first set the flag
so that get para knows what it has to do
and then
um for initializing we initialize the
parameters to an empty dictionary
call the messy annoying i'm sorry
i something wrong with my connection um
i
it has been a bit messy all day i hope
it's still getting through somewhat
um what we're going to be doing is
calling the messy function
it sets the parameter using the
initializer up here
and then we're going to take it
zero it out and return it um so that get
param knows it's allowed to return
things
i'm just using this thing again like
jokes on the impure user function it
thinks it's having
side effects but it doesn't because it's
running in our little sandbox
and so um set this to to none again
return the flag and return the result
and then this gives us the two functions
um this is a bit fast but i think if you
go through this
together with this um picture you'll
hopefully it'll hopefully make sense to
you
so what this allows us to do now is um
doing this here um and so this is
finally the purifying regressor as we
wanted
is inheriting from our flat fancy module
we just defined
and you see we write these nasty impure
functions that say
i want to get my parameter and i want to
initialize things
we have rmse we have predict and then
this is exactly the interface that we
wanted
it is creating this purified function
and this initializer function
we can get initial parameters um just to
show
that this actually works oops i should
have
executed that cell okay initial
parameters just like we wanted
it's so nice we didn't have to specify
this yes win
um and we can get the losses to the
gradients and update and you see that
yes
loss goes down this is still the same as
we wanted but you see that we're getting
more and more comfortable with every
little bit
completeness sake the final training
loop might something like uh might look
something like this
here i purify the prediction method i in
this case don't care about the
initializer because i already have
parameter dictionary and so now the
training loop is
very very concise i get the gradients
from my purify function
i'll update it and i want to print how
well i'm doing how close am i getting to
the seven that i want
and you see again training works fine
so that's all from the notebook um the
last thing i'm going to leave you with
is that as i hinted at what we've done
is
basically re-implement for all these
fancy frameworks
have been doing and so at the time i
wrote this blog post um
flax had just like sort of come out and
it was like this was pre linen
and so the most mature kid on the block
was haiku
and you see that what we did is very
similar to a haiku implementation
in particular we inherit from a
module-based class as does haiku
we have a method to get parameters as
does haiku
and we have this purification which
haiku calls
transform and again it takes an impure
function
and then gives us an init and an apply
function and that's exactly what these
functions were for us
um also this morning i was like hey
actually i wonder now that flax
this is linen rewritten it looks very
similar to which we didn't talk about at
all
because the worms but same idea um and
indeed
flaxslam looks very similar um the one
thing that's kind of different is we
have this nn compact thing um you can
look into that in the flat stocks for
more
details but other than that yep inherit
from a base class
yep have this function that gives us our
parameters if we want them to
and also has the initializers in there
and yep have an init
and an apply so it's exactly the same
idea
and if you understood what we were doing
while we're building this up
then these interfaces iq and a flags
linen um if you're interested in more
complicated examples and maybe a little
bit more
deep through this again do check out the
blog post um yes it is a year
old and i've changed code things a
little bit for these slides um to make
it nicer and more concise but
um i i still recommend it all the time
when friends want to learn jacks
and uh yeah follow me on twitter because
number go up
it's always good and i hope that was
uh useful to you all i realize we're a
little over time i'm
sorry for that um i don't know if we
have time for questions but also
you can email or dm me on twitter if you
have questions or
message me in the slack always happy to
answer
awesome thank you so much this was so
much fun
i loved the interactive part and
we had a lot of hearts and thumbs up for
um your notebook and for
the font as well so super cool yeah some
people ask if you
may want to share the notebook um your
blog post isn't turned
out yeah that would be great i was gonna
mention that
yeah i'm gonna link the um slides and
this little notebook and the recording
once it's up at that blog post um and
probably tweet about it or something
yeah
absolutely perfect thank you if you have
a little bit of time please do stick
around we had a few questions in the
chat and
later on i'll anonymize the chat and
maybe we could make it available as well
so if you have a bit of time please do
stick around
um yeah thank you so much we're a little
over time but i think it's totally fine
i would like to welcome our third
speaker today
uh mustafa ghani you're here all right
mustafa can you hear me hey yes yeah i
am here
oh welcome thank you so much for joining
us today
um it's the uh yeah third talk
uh today we're going to here and
yeah super excited um you'll be talking
uh about uh benchmarking transformers
and we're very excited to hear more
about it
yeah thank you very much thanks for
having me and and for for the
opportunity
to to talk about uh the long-range arena
the benchmark that we actually built uh
about a year ago uh do do you do you see
my slides by the way
yes that's good okay awesome okay great
okay
so i i wanted to basically talk it's
it's going to be a bit different from
the previous two tanks
and it's going to go a little bit uh um
the point is that this whole project uh
was uh
implemented uh like all the all the
baselines that we implemented there very
implemented in flags
uh and we really enjoyed it it was
actually a blast to to
have the chance of uh having like
jackson flags around when we decided to
do this otherwise it could have been
like
very like difficult and much harder
and uh but in general it's about the
uh like benchmarking efficient
transformers and variant that they are
actually
introduced for making computational and
decreasing to to
introduce to to decrease the computation
and memory cost of transformers
especially when they're dealing with
long sequences
so i i think i don't need to say any
things about this slide uh transformers
are everywhere
uh we're going to have also some talks
tomorrow about like transformers and
vision
um every day we hear like a slices of
transformer
in different applications um it seems
that they are
actually uh the the way to go at least
in short term or midterm
for future we don't know but i think uh
they are also inspiring a lot of
uh architectural contributions that are
coming on top of transformers
so what is happening here is that uh
uh basically we have uh this
self-attention which
which is the main uh or the heart of
transformers and
basically what we have is that we have
this token token interaction
which has the quadratic complexity and
then
uh this is a
this can be an issue especially if we go
to longer sequence length so
if we go to sequence lengths longer than
like 1k
or 2k or 3k uh this this might actually
slow down the whole things a lot
uh and the the point is that we have a
lot of problems and many domains that
we really need to deal with long
sequences like when we want to work with
line
text documents when we want to compare
them retrieve them
and model them uh if we want to actually
work with images if we really want to
actually work on pixel level images uh
like imagenet is 224x224
uh it's already a super long sequence
even with the patch-based processing of
images for for some application we
really need
small patches or overlapping patches or
when we actually work with megapixel
images
um we we patch-based processing of
images we still
deal with a super long uh set of
sequence of tokens on videos it's also
again obvious because we also have this
time dimension
uh so if we want to process videos or
like patches extracted from a frame
frames of videos
uh without any factorization again we
are
supposed to deal with long sequences and
and the last one is also pre-pre-trained
uh sequence modeling which
uh sorry protein uh sequence modeling
which is also
the motivation for some of these
efficient transformers that they came up
and uh there are actually many many
different variants of transformers um
coming up during past two almost two
years for
solving this issue in particular the
quadratic cost of uh
self-attention then when they they are
supposed to process
long sequences so we actually started
with writing a survey
uh we actually started actually studying
these uh these
transformers and and we wanted to
understand how these variants are
related and how they are
um how they basically
can we somehow introduce a sort of
taxonomy
to group them into different groups and
and understand how
how they uh like how these different
form of transformers came out with
respect to each other
and uh we wrote a survey on that which
um
i think it's also um one of the really
nice one
uh in terms of like grouping these these
different transformers we
we also talked about all the details
about these different models
and we also uh uh discuss
how um they did the memory and and like
computational cost of each of those and
compare them
uh we also talked about like the
constraint that they have some of those
for example are not applicable in
in decoding there is uh no
straightforward
or sometimes even impossible to uh do
the masking of the future
uh and uh and basically we group all
these into
four five different groups uh this
low-rank kernel
models fix factorized random patterns uh
learnable patterns memory and recurrence
uh and uh this is a bit old i think
if you want to start adding the uh the
transformer
uh that they came out and during past
year
uh probably they're going to be like 10
more different
ideas uh in this in this figure but uh
but i i recommend actually checking out
this survey
uh i i this that was actually one of the
i think i
never actually wrote the survey but this
one one of those that i really liked and
i think it was also pretty well received
by people who are working on efficient
transformers super import informative
for compiling different models
uh and then the question is that okay
you know you talked about that
but how do they compare in practice how
we can actually and quickly
check if they which one is better
and at the time that we were proposing
long-range i don't know i think still
there's no uh specific benchmark for
measuring
the uh the quality of these transformers
uh when they they've been um they've
been used in in long
sequence modeling problems and uh
and then the the goal was can we
basically find out a set up a set of
tasks that uh basically um in a unified
way we can
measure their their performance
as well as the cost of using each of
them in terms of memory usage or
or throughput and then we started
actually thinking about okay what do we
want
from this benchmark first of all we want
it to be a
general benchmark uh in a way that um at
least
we include tasks that that like uh um at
least the
the set of transformers that that the
efficient transformers that we had at
that time
are applicable on that so we stick with
for example encoding only tasks so no no
decoding or language modeling
um the other one was simplicity we
wanted to basically have
a setup for every task that is
simple so no other factors like data
augmentation or pre-training is involved
to
basically have a pure setup for
comparing transformers without
having other factors involved we wanted
these times to be challenging so they
should
not be so we didn't want to actually go
for a task that the transformers are
working
uh like with 99 percent accuracy uh
but but something that there is still
head uh room for
um for improvement and we wanted them to
be long uh which was actually the key
point of this whole benchmark and we
wanted to also
have these tasks probing different
aspects of
uh the like quality of the model in
terms of
for example how they are good in terms
of capturing the relations
uh or hierarchical and spatial structure
how they
do in terms of um generalizing over
length
how they do for modeling for example
transitivity
and different things that you can
actually
assume uh when you're dealing with long
sequences and
and also we wanted to stay in in a setup
that is um
as like as accessible as possible for
for
like people who are especially at
academia so
you don't need to have industry level
computing resources to to be able to
evaluate your transformer
and then we ended up with five different
tasks
we actually had i think 10 more uh but
we started actually pruning a bunch of
them and then we ended up actually with
these five tasks because they were
somehow representative and uh
there's less redundancy in terms of like
the aspects that they evaluate
and the first one is law and document
classification which is basically imdb
but with
a character level set up the other one
is a long documentary
line document retrieval or or matching
which is acl uh network
uh where we have two inputs and we are
uh two documents and we want to
basically match if they and if they are
related or not
uh each document has 4k lengths if we go
character level
uh and then the other one was list stops
which
which is a synthetic data set for
logical operate
operation and then this in some way
kind of assess the ability of models in
terms of
modeling hierarchical structure for
solving such a nested and
logical operation and then the other one
was image level
a pixel level image classification which
is simply c4
but uh the the model is supposed to work
on
a set of pixels instead of uh patches uh
or or any other thing so the sequence
link's pretty long
and also generalization is super hard in
in that and the other one was also
pathfinder
which i have two examples of that which
is basically an image task where you
really need to have this global
receptive field or
or having some sort of uh recurrence or
some sort of like
features in the architecture that that
is able to capture the transitivity
transitivity and the task is that you
have these palettes and then
you have two points and you're supposed
to
and they're like some some lines and
dashed lines
in in that palette and sometimes these
two points are connected
and they're also noisy not noisy um
like basically noise in these palettes
and sometimes they're not connected so
for example in
top example uh it's a positive example
and the bottom one
is a negative one and then this this
task is actually rooted from
some cognitive test which is also done
on human
uh cognition and perception and uh if if
you for example fit this uh there is no
way for example convolutions with with
uh local receptive field can can solve
this uh that there should be
some sort of as i said either a
recurrence or you need to see the whole
the whole patches or whole pixels in in
one go to be able to see if
these two points are connected or not so
that that's also
uh because it's also generated
synthetically we had two version of that
like one was basically
uh um 4k and the other one was oh sorry
it
one was 1k sequence length like 32 by 32
pixels and the other one was
16k which was a extreme version of
pathfinder we also wanted to know that
okay what is the the
like the characteristics of each of
these tasks so uh we did
some simple uh calculation in terms of
if we apply a normal transformer on this
task
what is the uh the the kind of like the
attention span
of a normal transformer for solving this
task and
the attention span span uh or or mean
is actually defined by the mean distance
between the query tokens
and every key tokens scaled by the
attention weight
uh in all heads and in all layers so we
just like collapse every
all these information into a single
number and then
we notice that for some of these tasks
you really need to basically attend to
to tokens that are uh really far from
each other for example in
in case of let's uh uh retrieval
you basically have your model in average
is actually attending over
um tokens that are 1 000 position away
from
from you uh which which also shows the
the point that uh
um i don't want to say that you need but
i
actually it's actually a proxy for the
model actually is using this uh global
receptive field
for solving this task so maybe it is
also needed in the
in the underlying uh solution that you
you are supposed to get to
uh so we evaluated 11 different
transformers
against these lro tasks uh local
attention uh
sparse transformer long former lean
former reformer
synchor transformer synthesizer big bear
linear transformer and
performer as well as the transformer
itself
and as i mentioned we implemented all
these in jackson
flags which was uh which was pretty nice
because i can imagine
implementing this in other frameworks
can can be a bit
more difficult or challenging uh but
uh but we uh well this is actually the
the
like basically scores on every
individual task on in every individual
uh like candidate model that we had
and uh for example uh we had this ldraw
score which is the average over all
these tasks
uh which you can say that the wiener is
here
big bear in terms of the performance but
this is not the whole story we also need
to check out the throughput
uh which is uh we measure that with the
step per second and also
the peak memory usage in terms of for
example gigabyte and then
you can see that uh first of all back to
the the performance you can see that
like different models they are um like
the
top score uh in each task is from
different models there's no like
absolute winners that that actually gets
the best score in all tasks
uh which kind of shows that there are
some inductive biases
introduced by the way that they want to
to tackle this computational cost
problem
which also um affect the way that they
converge to
a solution so they are actually
converging to different solutions so
it's not just controlling the
computation but also introducing some
inductive biases that is good for some
tasks
and is maybe not a good idea to have
that bias in other tasks
also pathfinder x we basically failed
to to generalize to the test set
uh with any of these transformers so
some of them are are doing basically a
good job in on the train time
but none of them were able actually to
to go away from the random
um score uh on on the pathfinder x
which is we we wanted to we wanted to
remove it and then we decided okay you
know let's keep it maybe someone
actually
comes up with a model that that does a
great job on this so
let's have it around back to the
speed or computational cost
and memory cost we plotted
all these models in this plot where the
x-axis is speed
the y-axis is l-ray score like the
quality of the model but
compressed in one single number which
again it's a bit you know it's not a
good idea to do that but
ah you know i mean like we just wanted
to to have one dimension
uh uh basically introducing the
uh or representing the the quality of
the model so we just averaged over that
all the tasks and then uh you can
see that basically what we have uh here
is the if a model goes to
top right uh position it's actually a
really good model which
highest which means high speed high
performance
but uh but there is always a trade-off
so
we have some models and by the way the
size of these nodes are basically the
memory
that they use or the pitch memory that
they use during training
and as you can see uh there's always a
trade-off and then uh
for example big bird was the absolute
wiener in terms of uh
like not absolute winner but like wiener
in terms of the the
uh the the elderly score uh it is pretty
slow uh compared to others and uh
for example something like um local
attention which is
kind of fast um it it doesn't get you
a a good result so it really depends
what you want to do
uh so if you want if you're looking for
the answer to this question that which
one
is the best one uh i i think it's
complicated
but in general we observed that
basically between all these models the
lean formula and performance and linear
transformers are
they they are basically offering a
rather good computer performance
tradeoff and
uh interestingly they all actually um
are from from this kernel uh and low
rank um
a group of methods that they want to
tackle the problem with long-range uh
uh line long sequence modeling
uh i just wanted to say that the code is
open source
uh the the data set is available
and you can actually go to to the github
page of long range arena and then
download the data set and
all these models are also implemented
there uh
we are receiving emails from different
people and
from from different uh research
institute and and and different
companies that
they're actually working on uh new ideas
for transformer models and this is super
exciting that that eldra
is actually giving them the opportunity
to directly compare
these models with the an existing set of
existing models
and also
it's also nice that people see this as
an opportunity to basically
think out of the box or i actually
really like this
tweet from oriole that like basically
think out of the circle
to come up with something that is not
really in this paradigm maybe someone
comes up with an idea that that is uh
solving this problem or
solving the quadratic complexity of the
self-attention
uh using a completely different idea and
completely different method
and we are actually looking forward to
see a model
right here uh up here and and which
which is super
good in terms of uh score and also super
fast
and uh really a small one and also
really memory efficient
uh i think that's it uh on my side i
think i
i just left seven minutes for questions
or
comments perfect thank you so much
mustafa we had
a lot of great feedback in the chat uh
when when you started talking about
excellent work uh really fantastic work
and somebody asked
if the code actually is open source and
you just confirmed yes
everything is available yes yeah yeah
the code for
the uh like the input pipeline for all
these data sets
the the data that we generated uh and
also the implementation of these
element models are all available in
their repo
that's great we did have a few questions
in the chat
maybe you want to have a look at it and
i'll read maybe some of them to you
one of them was if the learning problem
is
harder in terms of like sample
complexity
statistically speaking not speed wise
for problems with longer range
attention
sorry i i i missed the question so the
question is that
uh what why we have
difficult time learning problems that
they are dealing with lying sequences is
that the question or
um in terms of okay so yeah
yeah okay so the point is that yes uh
it really depends on the nature of the
task you know i mean we cannot really
compare
a uh sequence like like a list stops
um tasks or or a task that that that is
basically on on um um
answering the the uh the question for
given a
logical operation uh when the sequence
is 4k
and compare this with a like document
matching with 4k so like sequence length
is equal but they they
completely they they require completely
different
type of solutions or different things
are are
really important for solving these
problems i i think in in lr we are
we do uh we wanted to actually cover a
bunch of different tasks and
that that they actually cover uh capture
different aspects
but we really didn't study how the
like why they fail if they actually if
what one of these models they don't do a
good job
what what's what's happening on their
knees and we didn't actually really get
time to
to do this uh but there are there's
absolutely some some answer to this
where every specific
model there might be the the way that
they are solving the problem
might be uh something that is off about
solving this specific task
uh so i i think it it is something that
we didn't do
in this paper in this paper it was a bit
more about like on
proposing a benchmark having these
baselines implemented
and uh and comparing them uh in in high
level abstract
not not really in low level and
understand what's going on with every
single mother
and maybe related to what you just said
um
what is the long-term plan also for for
elra
you add results from from other
transformers in the survey
other models we actually interestingly
we decided to keep the archive paper
alive
so every six months we just add an
appendix with the latest
result that we have so people keep
sending us
code or or new results and we try to
somehow like verify and run the code or
somehow
find out that how the model perform and
then every time that we have something
confirmed
we just add it to a table in the in the
appendix
and then if you actually check so the
paper is on open review it's
kind of like fixed but the one in the
archive we are keep
we're keeping it updated so that there
are i think we have planned to do that
every six months
uh in terms of paper and also the the
github page
and we also want to keep that also uh
like it's not like a really professional
leaderboard but we want to keep that
also updated with the with the new ideas
that are coming
this is one thing another follow-up is
also
uh we want to really find out how these
transformers are
compared in terms of decoding and and if
we have a task that also involves the
coding like language modeling simply
right something like dambada
that that really requires um it's a
language building test but requires
capturing long range dependencies
uh that's also really interesting but
but uh probably some of these
models like lean former because it does
this low rank projection of the input
you somehow
lose the uh the the the the the meaning
of the sequence and position
at some point and then and this is not
really possible to do that
but that's also one of the one of the
feature direction for elrod to
to also explore tasks that they also
involve language modelling
or decoding great
and maybe we have time for one more uh
the last question that was asked here is
how do you compare these to perceiver
deep blind work and bottleneck based
approaches similar to that
uh while perceiver only does
classification don't you think that
learning compact
embeddings would be the way to go
forward for longer sequences
uh abs this is i i
i think that's a uh um
basically it's a valid comment that uh
as i said like
different uh for example if you think
about a star transformer
uh um that's also something that
introduces or solves the problem but in
a way
it um also has this like unavoidable
pulling mechanism
that every time that you want to process
a long sequence you
need to pull it and then the output of
this attention or
after this like um tension mechanism
that
is efficient on long sequence you have a
sequence a new sequence
and then for example if you want to do
that uh it's not just about the
embedding of the sequence uh
or something but also sometimes you
really need a
something like machine translation for
example like assume that you want to do
long document translation right and then
maybe you need a um like an encoder that
gives you
um embedding per token even not
embedding
pair like the whole input because most
of the time the attention again the
cross attention in in
machine translation is one of the key
component that gives you
the boost in the score so i think as
it would be really nice to see something
that doesn't really
change the way transformer works but
just makes it efficient instead of
introducing some constraint like
pulling or um making it possible only to
do classification
or maybe compressing the whole things
even in one embedding one like single
embedding
and that that's uh uh absolutely is a
bit constraining
um but uh but in general it's a valid
point that
we are looking for what i think to some
extent some of these are doing this job
but
they're not perfect but uh i think it's
interesting to see
those that they don't pose any extra
constraint on
on the setup that we have currently and
and those new models that are efficient
but
also applicable on to any task that
transformers are applicable
so that would be a a really great
direction
if people start working on
fantastic thank you so much mustafa
great great to
hear about your work um and yeah highly
recommended to check out the repo if you
haven't
already um thank you so much again and i
think it's we're perfectly on time for
the last talk of today um which is by
rohan
ron are you there
yes i'm here hi perfect hi welcome
um ron anil is uh also
at google and he'll be talking about
scalable second order optimization for
deep learning very excited to hear you
talk
thank you um so yeah if one of you could
give me a ten minute warning
uh for four thirty oh yeah sure yeah
cool
so yeah i'm ronan l uh i'm gonna talk
about
uh scalable secondary optimization for
deep learning has joined work with vinit
gupta tamar koran kevin reagan and joram
singer
we have the distributor jax
implementation link here
so my research focuses on making neural
network training efficient at scale
and this work is about making shampoo a
second order method
work well in practice uh there are
several other things that you can do to
make training efficient at scale uh so
some of them are listed
in these slides so why so largely we've
been
making small improvements to first order
methods and they've reached a plateau
both in terms of convergence and its
implementation performance
and what when second order methods give
the promise that you
you can get to the solution faster and
in in and possibly efficiently so
before we start the talk why is it
called shampoo because it has to do with
preconditioning
and this is credit to roy frostic who
came up with the name of the
optimizer so i'll just introduce a
general notion of preconditioning and
intuitively explain why this might work
so we have a function f that you're
trying to minimize and you have weight
vectors w
in rd for every time step you get the
gradient gt
and then you pre-multiply the gradient
by the matrix h t
h t is what we mean by pre-conditioning
so you're pre-conditioning gradients
with this matrix h t
if you get the second order gradient or
the hessian you get the newton method
and if you have exponential family you
get the fissure or natural gradient
and the focus of the stock would be
making efficient version of full matrix
adequate
on the right it's a very simple problem
of two parameters a quadratic
and it's an ellipse that's rotated and
scaled in one of the dimensions
so if you take gradient descent to the
towards the minima you would see that it
actually bounces off the level curves of
this function and zigzags to the
solution
if you had a good hd matrix you could
actually
pre-multiply it with the gradient so
that like your
loss surface looks spherical so geometry
geometrically you can think of the
preconditioner as
a way to scale and rotate your gradients
whereas the first order methods
only scale the gradients
so what is full matrix allocate
preconditional it's derived from the
online setting
essential idea or operation that you
have to do is take your gradient
vector take the outer products of
gradient vector and take the
uh inverse square root and this was
actually
jointly proposed in two papers in 2010
from google
however if you try to apply for matrix
at a grad to a
con of say a fully connected layer of 3.
3.5 k 2 by 2k
you would see that you would very soon
run out of memory because you would need
about 53 trillion weights to actually
keep this preconditioner
so what we typically do geometrically
you can think of as
take the take the uh diagonal elements
of the spray conditioner
and that's what we use and that's
diagonal adequate and that's what's used
in practice
and now you can add variations on top
where you
do not sum across all time steps you do
exponential moving average
in which case you get rms prop or
you can add momentum then you get an
atom clearly uh
the full matrix adder grad is quadratic
in memory in the total number of
parameters and cubic in the total number
of
income in computational cost whereas uh
diagonal methods or first order methods
as we call it
is quite cheap it's linear in memory and
linear in computation
so the quest question we have is uh can
we
have bring back some of these
correlations
between gradients of parameters as well
as uh
maybe in regimes where you are even
memory constrained can we build a better
method that
keeps less memory than diagonal adder
grad the answer is yes
so the talk today will be about shampoo
which is
basically combining ideas from these
three papers and we have another work on
sm3 which
which also has a jax implementation and
it allows you to reduce your memory cost
to sub linear uh space
so as you see here shampoo actually
reduces the memory cost to quadratic in
the dimension of the tensors and cubic
and the dimension
so it's almost uh starting to look
practical
so at a high level if you want to think
about uh shampoo you uh think of it as
first uh treat each of the layers in the
neural network independently so that's
the block diagonal approximation
and come up with the chronicle product
approximation to the full matrix at a
grad statistic
which i'll explain in the next few set
of slides so the the next three set of
slides is
mainly the crux of shampoo and once you
get it it's quite easy
to get to the rest of the slides so we
have a fully connected layer
um on the right you have a
dense network let's look at the weight
matrix for the first layer which is a
tensor of size four by five and you
would get a gradient
also of jack start gradient you would
get a gradient of size four by five
and just go with it and just compute
these two statistics
lt and rt um lte let's call it the left
left statistics and rt let's call it the
write statistics
and they're formed by just doing matrix
multiply between the gradient
matrix and its transpose and the other
one gradient transpose and
the gradient itself and then you can sum
across all time steps
so if you wanted to do full matrix at a
grad as i showed pictorially before
um you could take the gradient vector
which would be a 20
dimensional vector and you can take the
outer product and accumulate
and of course this would take a 20 by 20
matrix uh
and if when you have large number of
dimension uh when you like
when your layers are very large you you
would have you need to keep
a lot of memory so the shampoo
algorithm essentially proves this
learner order which you can basically to
prove that it converges
is is an approximation to full matrix
category by creating these chronic
product of these lt and rt matrices
so sketch of the shampoo algorithm it's
quite simple so on the left you add
these statistics uh
up over all time steps so you just
compute the
l plus g matrix multiplied by its
transpose similarly
uh symmetrically for the right uh right
statistics as well
and when you want to make an update you
actually only have to pre-multiply the
gradient with the left preconditioner
here the preconditioner is the inverse
phth root of the left statistics and on
the right you have the
inverse period throat of the right
statistic clearly this
could be expensive and this is one of
the challenges in actually making
any type of second order methods work
you would have to deal with matrix
inverses
usually so
the other challenge that we have when
applying shampoo to
uh increasing uh um into transformers is
this increasing model size
as you as you all know like the model
sizes have gotten very large
now when i when i started working on
optimization it was
300 million parameters but now it's
normal to have 100 billion parameter
models
so typically model sizes are
increased by increasing the number of
layers in which case
the shampoo memory only increases
linearly but if you increase the layer
width or
of course the shampoo breaks down
because now you have to
keep quadratic in the dimension of the
tensor and that's not going to work
so what we do is very simple so for
example this is a very large tensor
which is typical of transformer models
we have an embedding layer of size 32
768 by 1084
we find that actually on the left you
have a picture of a transformer you
actually improve convergence by just
keeping
one of the preconditioners the right
preconditioner and for uh models like
pctr prediction with the critical dlr
model
where you have number of vocabulary
items to be
186 million you can even efficiently
compute this by just taking the outer
product of the gradients of the input
layer
and we also see that it improves our
convergence there
so if you have a very large dense layer
it's also a block diagonal approximation
you can split those up into smaller
pieces
of 1084 by 1084 and run shampoo on each
of those and we still see improvement
and we will show you the results later
on rest net 50 where we
are able to train quite fast by
splitting it up into tensors of size 128
by 128.
in actual practice we also reshape the
gradients to increase the amount of
correlations for example if you have a
gradient tensor of size one three three
thousand twenty four thousand twenty
four we would reshape it to nine
thousand ninety four by thousand ninety
four
and typically the tensor and shampoo as
is constructed based on the
dimension of the tensors the tensor
dimension might be different based on
the implementation choices
so how do you compute these inverse peer
through it's very simple we just apply
the newton method uh
on you can run this on a gpu or a tpu
the newton method is the following x to
the power p
times a we are trying to compute the
inverse p thread of a should be equal to
the identity matrix
and that's the update equation that you
would get when you straightforward apply
the newton-raphson method
for matrices however that update
is that iteration is actually unstable
for and makes certain assumptions on the
eigenvalues of a
so we make a simple modification the
modification is to rewrite
x to the power p times a as m
and then you get to something called as
the coupled iteration
and you can see the jack squad for it
and this allows you to do very fast
inverses where you fast
inverse square roots and in very fast
inverse fourth roots
and you can find a lot more efficient
methods in this book
the other problem that we have to deal
with is uh these statistics matrices
might be very
poorly conditioned so this is the
overton rule of thumb
for matrix functions a function like
inverse p root
you would lose these many bits of
position so here copper
of m the matrix that we're trying to
compute the inverse p
root is basically the maximum eigenvalue
of the matrix divided by the minimum
eigenvalue
and if you have something like float32
and you're trying to
compute the inverse p at the fourth root
of it you would lose about 19 bits of
precision and
essentially you're left with four bits
of precision which means that you might
not get the full benefit of
preconditioning
so this is what happens in a real model
the inverse b at roots we're looking at
the maximum
minimum singular values we see that we
do see large condition numbers
so what could you do to address this uh
you
you you have to run these inverse pth
roots which are expensive but
it's done for each layer and so there's
a natural parallelism
one thing you could do is to run these
inverse sphere through its on
the cpus that have that is doing your
input pipeline
so what you do that do in jax is to
outside your device loop you would
gather your statistics and compute these
inverses
and push back those preconditioners back
into the tpu
this works quite well and you can
implement this
uh if you have a very large training
pipeline and
we find in practice that you don't
actually need to run these inverse peer
throughs very often
for transformer models we find that a
delay of thousand steps is
more than sufficient to get most of the
benefits from preconditioning
the other thing you could do if you
don't have high precision numerics is to
actually emulate them using
b like smaller precision so for example
this paper from intel shows how you can
leverage b float 16 units to actually
emulate floating point 32 units
so it's using fewer more matrix multiply
but this means that you don't actually
have to have these big
area on the chip to do this matrix
multiplication
so which uh so this allows us to
actually move the inverse sphere through
to the accelerator that's running the
computation and the choice of where you
would put it
is based on what type of model you're
training and many of the properties of
the model for example if you have a very
large
batch training you would need to compute
the preconditions very often
and if you have very small batches you
can usually have
stateless tolerance of a thousand steps
as i said before
and there are many other trade-offs so
jax for example gives you very easy way
to
select the precision you want so for
example i'm just doing a matrix multiply
and these uh this is in this is part of
the inverse pier root you have to do
uh matrix multiply by itself and you can
actually configure it by
passing a precision flag and depending
on the hardware that you run on on a gpu
or a tpu you would get the right
amount of precision and this allows us
to actually implement shampoo
with uh on jacks natively running
the inverse pair throat on the tpu
itself the second problem with
second order methods is that you
actually have a very expensive
computation that you have to run
and you have to run that in if it's in a
data panel regime you have to run that
in every core
typically first order method
implementation ignores this because it's
quite cheap it's just
element-wise operation so you just run
them independently once you sum the
gradients on every core
so jax provides quite powerful
primitives like pmap and vmap that
allows you to parallelize your
expensive operation across course you
probably already use this
so for example you can compute the
inverse p at the root across
all the statistics across all the
devices in a single host or a multi-host
setting and here is some
sort of actual code that i copied from
the shampoo implementation
that allows you to do this
so what happens when you put all of
these together for
a real model where there is like a
benchmark
that's competed on by several hardware
companies
so we actually get to be the fastest in
training
for example this resnet 50 at a very
large batch sizes like for example this
is 32 768
and it uses the same benchmarking
hardware and it actually
beats first order methods and gets about
31 reduction in
uh training time now um we use block
preconditioning as i described earlier
this allows us to run these inverses
every step
and it's quite fast so we actually uh
used this and
recently we submitted this to the mlperf
1.0 open submission and you can find
even faster results there
so we recently used this to actually
improve a real
use case where you actually wanted to
train um
a rest net 50 to the highest possible
accuracy so in this paper we actually
we actually use shampoo to get about a
forex reduction in training time
to get rest net 50 to the same accuracy
so this
lesson at 50 gets to about 82.8 percent
accuracy and you can read about it in
this paper
and clearly a lot of people are probably
interested in transformers
uh these are some of our results where
we were running these inverse field
routes every thousand steps
we actually uh pretty much do better
than
adam well tuned atom in a couple of data
sets
and also across our domains for example
for pctr prediction task
the improvement that we see here is
quite large
so as i said you have the gradient
tensor and you pre-multiply it by a
preconditioner on the left and a
post conditioner or right
pre-conditioner on the right
so this is like snapshot of a
pre-conditioner from a transformer
training for a language translation task
we find that there's actually patterns
that show up
for example this on the right there are
these block diagonal
things that could possibly be from the
multi-head attention
on the left here have these four blocks
with these non-diagonal patterns which
probably are from uh modeling maybe
sequences that are the tokens that are
closer together
um we actually notice that when you
apply these matrix multipliers you
change the signs you are literally
rotating the gradient
significantly and that allows you to get
faster convergence
so the other work is sm3 which is a
sublinear memory
optimizer this allows you to actually
[Music]
if you have a regime where you're
training large
training with large number of parameters
and you don't have enough memory to keep
optimizer state like the second moments
in adam you could use sn3 which is a
version of countman sketch
to compress it into a sub-linear space
so think of this as the diagonal entries
of the diagonal of the shampoo matrices
that i showed you
so oh i am ahead in time so i have
uh so this is the talk uh sm3 is already
available in uptake so you can use it
shampoo is already available in the pre
linen version of flax
and the optics version will be out this
week if you have any questions let me
know
and we can use the next 10 minutes to
maybe
ask ask me questions and i can answer
them
awesome thank you so much super
impressive results
um we did have a few questions that you
maybe partially addressed already um so
the comparison between sm3 and shampoo
you mentioned briefly
yeah so um sm3 you can think of it as it
pretty much matches adam and shampoo
does better than adam in majority of the
cases
and let's see um you also said it is
available
somebody asked if it is available kind
of as a straight
out of the box for straight out of the
box usage
yeah you can if you use black you can
call the
[Music]
the distributor shampoo from our code
base it's open source
um i have the link in the first slide
you can just
use that to train your models awesome
and how's the performance of shampoo in
gpu versus tpu
so it's about i haven't done
very large amount of benchmarks because
i mostly use tpus
so it depends on a lot of things like
how fast
like for example tpu is a very efficient
communication so these p maps run
blazingly fast
on gpus you need to have nv-link and
other things to get those communication
to be fast so it sort of
depends on the hardware you have so it's
a very
nuanced question to answer so it depends
on the versions of each of these
devices somebody asked about type of
parameters
um how well do those values transfer
for a task to another task um
a great question these are the
hope was that second order methods would
allow you to do
fewer hyper parameters but that's not
true it's the same amount of
hyperparameter tuning as first order
methods
the default one generally does well uh
but once you tune
those hyper parameters equally well as
first order methods you get better
results
cool and um let's see
are there some use cases where we should
use
sm3 versus shampoo
right so um it depends on the model so
if so like uh open question that we
haven't answered is that
do you need to train a very large model
or you need to train a smaller model
with a better optimizer
so what is the efficiency gains from a
better optimizer in decreasing your lock
perplexity or whatever
metrics you're looking for it's not
clear to me
right now so for example if you can
increase the number of parameters to the
point where you don't have enough memory
to store atoms so in which case you
could use sn3 so that's a quite open
question
one thing i could see is the smaller the
model the more hyperparameter
tuning you could do so you could
probably
see benefits so for example in the
uh in the one place where we actually
have data
is this pctr prediction task so the
improvement that we get here
is more than what you get by making the
embedding sizes
8x larger so if you make the models 8x
larger
you get about 0.2 0.25 or something and
we
get way more than that by just using a
better optimizer so
ideally if you you have the hardware you
should do both
um is shampoo less sensitive to how you
set the overall learning rate
so it's very again uh
that's sort of like uh for the interest
net experiments the
i've the all the hyper parameters for
different batch sizes are checked in
it actually um like what we find is that
when you tune
uh there's no like linear scaling law or
something that we
you typically prescribe uh the batch
size is 32 768 uses a learning rate of
16 because of
related to how the gradients are summed
and the batch size of 65k
uses a learning rate of 12. so unclear
to me how to actually answer this uh
we've been answering it by parameter
tuning so giving equal amount of
tuning to baseline and the optimizer to
see which one works better
makes sense um we have a question on
your your background
uh someone is really interested in your
research background and how did you
converge toward your current line of
research
uh i've been at google research for the
last
six years now i've been working on
applied machine learning for those
amount of time
and i uh been working on i guess applied
ml at google uh on internal products
and i guess in the last three years i've
been
and even during those times i was mostly
working on efficiency
different types so before doing research
i was actually
programming i guess a systems programmer
working on optimizing
actual servers and things like that
in terms of research career i guess the
efficiency makes me like
motivated because it's real and
yeah so hope that answers the
question yeah cool um
there's one more question coming in on
these plots it looks like
models didn't converge yet do you expect
final performance would be different
better for shampoo versus atom yeah so
typically
so for transformer models these
improvements are consistently
like this across um time steps
one could do learning rate decay at the
very end to get
some performance out of averaging and
that
is like on par for both cases uh so it's
yeah so it's typically uh you would see
the same type of results
in large scale what i've seen is shampoo
gets to gets to better quality
but it might be just trainability if you
show more
data to the first order methods it
probably reaches the same accuracy
for example um it's kind of verified in
the
um resonant 50 experiments here so
like atom atom is the blue line it also
reaches the same accuracy given enough
time